you would think the smell would be the
worst part and don't get me wrong it was
far from pleasant to say the least that
pungent odor a stomach turning scent
like raw sewage it wasn't just dirt and
decay now it was far more disgusting
than that it had that awful metal tang
to it that meant when that awful stench
crawled its way up your nose it lingered
hanging at the back of your throat
choking you on the sickening reek that
lay thick in the air like a foul
smelling fog and yet like i said that
was far from the worst part what was
well even the sight of what had happened
to him wasn't what made me feel
unsettled hardly any of his body was
visible covered in that writhing
shifting cloak but i could see it move
each tiny piece of the mass moving on
its own it made me imagine what it must
have felt like to have all those little
scratchy legs and pinchers claws and
teeth hooking into his skin and that the
idea of what it would feel like that was
the worst part about seeing the vermin
god city life isn't really all it's
cracked up to be ask anyone who lives in
a big urban area and they'll likely tell
you the same those bright lights and
tall spires reaching up to the clouds
they offer the promise of prosperity
opportunity and even fame and fortune
for those who are extra naive but when
they upped sticks packed their bags and
moved here to start a new life they
realized that all long they'd been sold
on a dream a false fantasy that is just
simply too good to be true of course by
the time they get here it's already too
late and before they know it they're
knee-deep in debt trying to keep up with
paying rent on an apartment that's
barely big enough for one person if you
aren't careful a big city can swallow
you up sometimes literally never mind
just desperately trying to make ends
meet and keep yourself afloat there's
also plenty of danger to be found in the
heart of the city it doesn't take much
for people to lose themselves in the
darker parts of this metropolitan hell
pretending it's a haven and when they do
that's usually where my job starts i've
been working as a private investigator
for coming up on a decade my specific
job title had gone through a number of
rebrands and different combinations of
terms over the years cassius duke
detective for hire then private eye and
freelance investigator after that and
don't fall under the same sort of
assumptions that most people do when
they hear all those terms believe me
just like the city's promises it rarely
lives up to what you'd imagined it to be
like my life was never high speed chases
and gunfights solving murders and
tracking down crooks that robbed banks
and clown masks that was work for the
real police allegedly much higher above
my pay grade now that i had quit most of
the time i dealt with uncovering the
various dirty little secrets this grimy
city had to offer more often than not my
job was working as either a spy or
enforcer that anyone could hire i
followed around the rivals of wealthy
businessmen snapping photos of them with
my camera to get any dirt i could that
my more unethical clients would probably
use for blackmail or i'd be warning
stalkers to keep away from whoever they
were causing trouble for usually with a
bit of
gentle encouragement in the form of some
pretty stern words and a wrap on the
knuckles of sorts it was ugly work but
that suited just how ugly the underside
of this whole city was
some of my clients were often desperate
people folks who the ordinary system of
law and order had failed when that
happened when they had been turned away
by the cops on the verge of losing any
hope they had left that was usually when
they turned to me for help now i don't
work for free of course you get nothing
for nothing everything's got its price
so on and so forth but i wasn't looking
to extort people especially at their
lowest moments so firm but fair i
charged them a little bit for my time
maybe a finder's fee if i happened to
come across some dirt that was really
worth some extra cash it was rare for me
to take on a job pro bono as it were
without expecting any pay for my
services but when this case landed in my
lap i felt obligated to do the job for
free it was another gray day in a gray
city a knock on the door interrupted me
from my busy schedule of staring at the
paint flaking off my ceiling after i'd
called them through the person
responsible for that knock came stepping
cautiously into my office he told me his
name was martin jenkins but that his
friends called him marty sorry i i don't
really know how all this works martin
admitted making no attempt to mask how
nervous he was well why don't you take a
seat first i sighed that's a start oh
okay he replied awkwardly pulling up a
chair and sitting down opposite my desk
so mr jenkins what can i marty he
interjected mr jenkins i repeated what
is it that brings you here well someone
said you might be able to help with my
um problem martin said sheepishly and
what sort of problem are you having mr
jenkins i push for him to give me a
straight answer i didn't really have a
lot of patience for anyone who wasted
time just getting to the point
it's my brother you see the other mr
jenkins he finally confessed he's been
missing it's actually been months now a
missing person's case is a police matter
i'm sorry but you'll have to go to them
as bad as it felt turning the guy down
at a time like this i had my profession
to protect if i wasn't careful the cops
would come down on me like a ton of
bricks i'd already ruffled up some
feathers in that area not long before
i'd taken a case where and i'd
accidentally photograph some corrupt
officers accepting bribes one of those
pictures wound up on the evening news
there'd been a target on my back ever
since but detective duke martin began to
say mr duke i corrected him i've already
tried going to the police they wouldn't
even accept a a missing person's case
when i explained what happened to my
brother go on i said reaching for my
notebook and a pen on the desk i left
the city a while ago after my brother
and i melvin his name's melvin jenkins
we we had an argument
and
what was it that triggered this argument
i asked dragging my pen across the page
it was
well a lot of things martin's side our
father died almost a year ago it wasn't
unexpected but
mel took it pretty hard then the doctors
told us the condition dad had carried a
chance of being hereditary so we both
went to get tested i didn't show any
signs of developing it but melvin did
he took it as a death sentence got very
low and started wasting all of our
inheritance on every vice he could get
his hands on drinking partying gambling
you name it he was doing it and this led
to the argument i probed it did i
confronted him before i left town i was
mad that he'd been using all our dad
left us for such frivolous and
irresponsible things marvin continued
his story almost unable to stop now he's
started he didn't want to hear any of it
said he was going to die eventually
anyway so what was the point and i told
him he was selfish and that was the last
time we spoke when did you notice he was
missing as soon as i came back from out
of town he answered i went to the
apartment dad had left us that too along
with all the payments still due and i
found that mel was gone apparently he
had better in a card game and lost badly
i had no way of finding him nobody else
knew where he was let me guess i stepped
in when he went to the police they said
he's most likely living on the streets
which would make him a lot harder to
find martin nodded solemnly clearly
feeling guilty for what had happened
although from where i was sitting it was
his brother's own misgivings that had
created this situation i went on to ask
a few more background questions before
asking if mr jenkins could provide me
with a photo of his missing brother he
obliged handing over a printed picture
the moment i saw it i offered to take
the case for free his brother melvin i
recognized him almost instantly he was
in his mid or possibly late 30s average
height and build in the picture far
better shape and a lot cleaner than when
i'd seen him but it was that same guy
that much i was sure of no amount of
unshaved stubble or disheveled clothing
could change that i'd seen him seen
melvin outside my building a few times
sleeping rough on the sidewalk every day
that i showed up to start another day of
work i drop him a few dollars anything i
had in my wallet at first i told myself
it was for good luck so i didn't attract
any bad karma for myself but when i
actually paid attention to how he was
living gesture became what it should
have been from the start it wasn't about
me or sparing myself bad luck it was
just about trying to help out someone
who needed it when i was in a position
to do him a small kindness at the very
least one night i just locked up my
office and i was about to head home as i
stepped off the curb head down eyes on
my phone a truck came speeding down the
street i would have been killed
instantly had a hand not grab me and
pulled me back onto the sidewalk melvin
had hauled me out of harm's way he
didn't say anything to me and i failed
to do anything more than just thank him
verbally before heading home so i
figured i owed him one well i didn't
tell his brother this it had been a few
months since i last seen melvin outside
my building i'd always assume he moved
on or been asked to move by an
overzealous cop of course that meant
figuring out where he was going was
going to be tricky exactly the reason
the police had turned martin away when
he'd asked them for help locating his
brother but i had a few connections that
even if they hadn't seen melvin might
have at least heard something or could
know someone else that had seen him it
wasn't a lead yet but it was a start dee
was the head of the city's biggest
homeless shelter and a good friend of
mine so she became my first port of call
i showed her the photo of melvin and
asked if he'd come to stay at the
shelter recently doesn't ring a bell i'm
afraid she looks somberly at the picture
sorry duke i wish i could be more help
not on you i replied taking the photo as
she handed it back to me you mind if i
ask around see if anyone here recognizes
him be my guest dee said i spent about
an hour milling around asking a few down
on their luck folks if they recognized
the man in the photo a few of them
mentioned they'd seen him around here
and there sleeping rough in a number of
different parts of the city but none of
them could give me anything concrete no
definite location i'd be able to search
next that was until one of them spoke up
he was an older guy but dabbled clothes
and unwashed hair with a thick beard who
had been craning his neck to try and
sneak a look at the photo when i'd been
showing someone else i seen him the man
clarence said matter-of-factly you
recognize this man i asked to verify
said i seen him he repeated looks
different now though well that's to be
expected i replied i don't mean he's
gotten skinnier because he ain't been
eaten clarence said in retort i mean
that he don't even look like he's human
no more what does that mean i questioned
looking back at the bearded man in
confusion that man right there stopped
being a man no idea when or how it
happened but last time i saw him it was
already too late nowadays he's the
vermin god i didn't really have much of
an idea of how to respond unsure if
clarence was pulling my leg and
deliberately wasting my time if there
was some truth to this bizarre urban
legend at any rate it was the only real
lead i had so far albeit a tenuous one
at best so i pressed the old man to tell
me where he'd seen melvin of this vermin
god as he kept calling in there's an
abandoned warehouse down on the
waterfront clarence had explained i knew
the place he meant it used to be a go-to
for people who were sleeping rough lots
of us used to stay there but that's when
the pests got bad bests what kind of
pests all kinds rats roaches you name it
then just we were having to deal with
them the company that owned the building
sent cops down to clear us out told us
it was unsafe and we should move on it
was sitting there empty for ages so i
decided to chance it head down there and
see if we could start using the place
again but when i went to look he was
there waiting in the dark and he wasn't
alone he ain't ever alone they're always
with him all around him i chose to
ignore clarence's attempts at unnerving
me getting him to confirm once again
that it was in fact melvin he had seen
my next call was following up on this
wild story so so i hopped on to the next
bus across town
huddled together with commuters holding
on to ceiling rails swaying with every
turn of the bus like we were meet
hanging in the back of a butcher's van i
walked quite a bit from the bus stop
towards the docks most of the area was
restricted off limits to members of the
general public given how hazardous it
could be i wasn't concerned in my line
of work i usually had to get into places
i wasn't supposed to be pulling a pair
of wire cutters from my jacket pocket i
snipped through the chain-link fence
that surrounded the warehouse clarence
had directed me to the place wasn't
guarded after all it was empty lifting
up the wire mesh and slipping underneath
through the gap i grabbed my flashlight
and headed in the warehouse was well and
truly deserted previously used for
storage but now just an empty space that
was being left vacant wasted in its lack
of use all around was silence
occasionally broken by beads of water
dripping from the skylight into a puddle
on the ground suddenly i heard a new
noise a crunch of something being
squashed under the sole of my shoe i
lifted my foot and shown my torchlight
downwards looking to see what i just
stepped on it was a cockroach far bigger
and fatter than anyone i'd ever seen
smashed to pieces underneath my shoe i
stamped the rest of it off a little
disgusted as how everyone gets when they
see a roach dead or alive that's when i
noticed another sound a low dull buzzing
my initial thought was that it was
electrical maybe a generator that was
still running i started searching around
for the source of the sound thinking
that if i could flip the switch it might
turn on some lights in here that would
make searching for melvin a little
easier suddenly as i turned a corner the
buzzing sound got louder it wasn't just
closer it was angrier more intense what
was worse was that i'd walk directly
into a cloud of something or lots of
somethings tiny flies were whizzing past
my ears the noise of their wings so
close it was almost deafening meanwhile
even more were zipping around my face
landing on my skin and rubbing their
little germ-coated legs together waving
my arms wildly i tried my best to
disperse the swarm clearing a few of
them away as i tumbled into the next
room my flashlight clattered to the
floor as i crawled over to pick it back
up blindly swatting more of the insects
away in the dark that's when i saw him
the vermin god with no light in the room
only the beam from my flashlight i
hadn't noticed it at first the second
the light fell over the writhing mass it
shifted as a matter of fact it didn't
stop moving not once it was a seething
assortment of vermin mostly black rats
their fur wet with what i could only
assume was water straight from the sewer
but there was more worms huge spiders
thick roaches dropping off of the huge
shape as it turned it stood up a mass of
animals and insects standing like a man
lumbering towards me creatures were
falling off with every step only to
crawl back in and join the rest i pushed
myself back on the floor trying to get
away from what i assumed to be a
horrific monster
something controlling all the rats and
vermin making them form around it like a
cloak of pure filth and decay the stench
of it as well that foul unclean smell
hanging in the air and lingering at the
back of my throat made me want to be
sick it was so repugnant that it kept me
crawling back until my back was pressed
up against the wall trapping me between
it and the vermin god it leaned closer
reaching out an arm covered in grime and
cockroaches all crawling over each other
i turned away and closed my eyes yelling
out into the dark for anyone to come and
help a voice said weekly i looked up at
it panting and shaking in fear with
trembling fingers i lifted my flashlight
higher right up to the head of the
vermin god beneath the mass of rats
crawling over it and the bugs wriggling
about below them a pair of eyes glinted
in my flashlight's beam human eyes they
were eyes i'd seen before the same
hopelessness behind them as when he used
to ask for change outside my building it
was melvin that's when i started to see
beneath the vermin coating his body
catching brief glimpses of his arms and
chest just as one rat moved but before
another slipped in and took its place
his skin was pockmarked with bites and
scratches some fresh and still bleeding
others that had started to dry beneath
the shroud of crawling insects and
rodents his face had gotten gaunt coated
in a thick layer of dirt he wasn't
controlling these things if anything the
vermin seemed to be using him as some
kind of host just as i edged a little
closer to him considering the idea of
reaching into the mass and pulling
melvin free one of the rats bit me i
dropped my torch at the pain of the tiny
needly teeth piercing my skin and
started to feel more of them crawling up
my ankles i turned heel and ran all the
way out of the warehouse by the time i
was far enough away the rats that had
left onto me had crawled back off
heading back inside into their vermin
god now go and check out
scp-1025 encyclopedia of common diseases
and
scp-3760 like a doll's eye for more
sickening stories of other anomalous
illnesses that are guaranteed to make
your skin crawl or maybe that's just the
rats you're feeling